para gago de un año después entre la
esperanza y la resignación
alberto fernández llegó al poder en
argentina para recuperar la maltratada
economía del país algo que no ha
sucedido a la crisis heredada se sumó la
pandemia del cob y 19 a toda la
argentina a todos los argentinos a todas
las argentinas a partir de la cero hora
de mañana deberán someterse el
aislamiento social preventivo y
obligatorio una respuesta al coronavirus
que empezó siendo admirada pero que lo
ha ido desgastando pese a uno de los
confinamientos más largos del mundo
argentina es el tercer país de américa
latina con más muertes tampoco ha
logrado iniciar la recuperación
económica aunque se han visto sus
intentos de llevar a cabo una política
social con las ayudas de pandemia o una
novedosa ley de impuestos a los ricos
rechazada por la oposición ligada al
presidente matriz por los afectados
además del impulso directamente desde
presidencia de la ley de legalización
del aborto enviaré al congreso de la
nación para su tratamiento
dos proyectos de ley para que todas las
mujeres accedan al derecho a la salud
integral un hito de gobierno que
comparte con la reestructuración de la
deuda y la renegociación con el fmi con
la que consiguió extender vencimientos
de pago y reducir las tasas de interés
aunque el problema de la deuda dista de
estar resuelto y que hoy con
tranquilidad podemos decir que el
objetivo que nos fijamos lo hemos
logrado
para la argentina el acuerdo que hemos
alcanzado significan 37 mil 700 millones
de dólares menos que deberemos pagar en
los próximos 10 años en política
internacional este primer año podría dar
lugar a un liderazgo de argentina en
mercosur
fernández se ha acercado al presidente
de brasil their bolsonaro para forjar
alianzas en la región
aunque la oposición lo acusa de haberse
kitchen izado son evidentes las
distancias con la antigua mandataria y
ahora vicepresidenta cristina fernández
de kirchner
bajo cuya sombra ha gobernado este año
2021 servirá para comprobar si se
confirman las expectativas previas a su
elección o bien en los comicios de mitad
de mandato vuelve a haber un giro
político en el país un reto que en buena
medida dependerá de la gestión de la
vacunación que él quiere convertir en
una epopeya porque alberto fernández no
será juzgado tanto por lo que prometió
sino por lo que le tocó como él mismo
dijo somos los gobernantes de la
pandemia y así nos recordarán
[Aplausos]